Herzlich Willkommen zum Chaosradio 260, das allen Widerständen zum Trotz heute stattfindet, ja. Wir wollen heute über ein Thema reden, wo die Leute, die über das Thema oder wegen denen über das Thema reden, vielleicht sagen würde, das könnte verhindert werden, wenn die Mächte, die die Welt regieren, da eingreifen. Kurz gesagt wollen wir heute über Lügen, die die Gesellschaft radikalisieren, reden und haben dazu zwei Gäste eingeladen. Zwei Autorinnen, die auch mehr oder regelmäßig Podcasten und Bücher zum Thema herausgebracht haben. Das eine ist Fake Facts wie Verschwörungstheorien denken bestimmen von Katharina Nocun und das andere ist Hasskrieger über den globalen Rechtsextremismus von Karolin Schwarz und beide sind jetzt bei mir hier zu Gast. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. So und das Thema ist schon deshalb schwierig, weil es nicht zum ersten Mal auftaucht. Also die Stichworte sind es gerade Bill Gates, Impfverschwörung, 5G, Grundgesetz abschaffen oder schützen. Man weiß nicht so genau, es geht also um Verschwörungserzählungen oder Verschwörungsmythen und das ist aber so ein Thema, weil es da um Sprache geht, wird es auch gleich am Anfang schwierig. Es ist ja gerade im Nordkontext gibt es das Bild von den Aluhüten oder wie man auch schon sagt, Verschwörungstheoretiker, die Verschwörungstheorien und das Folgbringen. Und genau das aber ist schon die erste Diskussion, die wenn man über dieses Thema redet, man anbringen muss, nämlich man soll nicht mehr Verschwörungstheorie sagen.
Nee, es gibt ja vor allem auch ein massives Angebot an Informationen. Das, glaube ich, schon ein Teil ist. Also es gibt ja diese aktuellen Erhebungen auch zur Einstellung, zu Impfungen und so weiter, während der Corona-Krise. Und man sieht schon zum Beispiel da ja teilweise, dass so ein bisschen der Trend zur Informationsvermeidung geht. Weil es eben teilweise zu negativ ist, aber auch weil es eben so ein massives Angebot ist. Und es teilweise schwer ist zu filtern. Also ich kenne das aus meinem Umfeld, das ja auch zum Glück auch aus Nicht-Journalisten besteht. Dass es da natürlich einen ganz anderen Zugang zu Informationen und Nachrichten gibt. Weil die Zeit eine ganz andere ist, wenn man sehr, sehr unterschiedlich mit Freizeit- und Freizeiteinteilung umgeht. Und da ist das schon ein Faktor. Das nehme ich aus meinem Umfeld auf jeden Fall wahr. Aber das ist eben auch anecdotisch aktuell.
Ich würde gerne für die aktuellen Verschwörungserzählungen noch zu einer Auswirkung kommen, von der ich nicht genau weiß, ob es die wirklich gibt oder ob das nur eine Beobachtung ist. Es gab am Rand von so Hygienedemos ein paar Berichte von Gewalt gegen Journalisten. Da gab es dann einen kleinen Aufschrei, der war unter Kolleginnen. Das ist jetzt eine neue Qualität der Gewalt am Rande, die der Verschwörer nehmen muss. Wir hatten auch bei Breitband ein Interview mit Simone Raphael, die meinte, zynisch gesehen kann man sagen, das ist eigentlich nichts Besonderes. Aber im Sinne von auf Demonstrationen, wo Rechtsextreme sind, findet auch Gewalt gegen Donalismus statt. Aber gibt es da einen Zusammenhang zwischen Verschwörungserzählung und Gewaltbereitschaft, der sich jetzt vielleicht auch ändert? Also sind Menschen, die einer Verschwörungserzählung glauben, ihr bereit, diese auch mit Gewalt zu verteidigen?
Ich glaube, diese Gewaltneigungsfrage würde ich gleich noch an dich weitergeben, Kata, aber ich würde kurz antworten auf diese Journalismusfrage und auch die Angriffe. Also erstmal muss man im Einzelfall schauen, was auch die Ermittlungen ergeben noch. Dieser Angriff auf das Heutesshow-Team, das fand ich schon ziemlich erschreckend, weil es so ein massiver Angriff von einer größeren Gruppe wohl war, die eben ein Team, das gerade überhaupt nicht gefilmt hat, angegriffen hat. Das fand ich schon ziemlich heftig. Andere Sachen, die wir gesehen haben, fand ich tatsächlich auch wenig überraschend. Und ich hab vorher in Leipzig gewohnt, sehr, sehr lange. Und Pegida und Legida sitzen mir eigentlich heute noch in den Knochen. Also ich kenn eigentlich kaum jemanden, der von den Demos berichtet hat, der nicht in irgendeiner Form zumindest verbal, aber teilweise auch ziemlich heftig körperlich angegangen wurde. Und insofern ist das, finde ich, nichts Neues. Was ich gesehen hab, also ich war auf einer der Demos und hab mir das angeschaut, am 1. Mai. Und also das war genau der Tag, an dem auch der Angriff auf das heute schon Team erfolgt ist, glaube ich. Und was ich beobachtet hab, war weniger Aggression gegenüber Journalisten. Das bin ich von Rechtsextremen Demos sehr, sehr viel mehr gewöhnt teilweise. Aber dafür sehr, sehr viele Einzelpersonen, die extrem aggressiv die Polizisten angeschrien haben. Dass ich so in der Form zum Beispiel wiederum nicht aus den Rechtsextremen Demos so massiv kenne. Da gab es teilweise schon noch ein paar Unterschiede, die ich wahrgenommen habe. Also grundsätzlich kann man aber auch sagen, sowohl aus diesen verschwörungsideologischen Demos, die ja auch teilweise Hooligans und sonstige angezogen haben in verschiedenen Teilen Deutschlands, als auch von Pegida und Co. Ist man tatsächlich inzwischen mehr oder minder gewöhnt, dass man mit einem Kamerateam auch inzwischen mit Sicherheitsleuten unterwegs ist. Das ist leider nicht ganz so neu.
Ja, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich hatte auch eine Medienanfrage. Da hieß es so, ja, haben Sie Lust vor Ort, die Demo mit einem Kamerateam zu kommentieren? Wir haben auch Sicherheitsleute dabei. Und da habe ich direkt gesagt, so nee, sorry. Also abseits davon, dass wir gerade eine Pandemie haben und dass mir eine Massenveranstaltung jetzt nicht so verlockend erscheint. Ja, mit dem Kamerateam.
Holy shit, liebe Kollegen, was zur Hölle.
Ja, ich hatte die gleiche. Ich habe sie auch abgesagt und finde sie auch schwierig.
Ja, vor allem gerade, wenn man eh schon so aus diesem Milieu halt so diverse Fanposts bekommt mit diversen verbalen Ausschmückungen, wie unser erstes Date aussehen könnte. Um es mal vorsichtig zu formulieren, hat man da jetzt nicht so unbedingt Bock drauf. Also ich kann aber auch verstehen, dass man natürlich auch vor Ort berichten will. Aber als Expertin möchte ich dann nicht unbedingt in Kombination mit einem Filmteam dann quasi mir, hallo, hier bin ich, so groß auf die Brust schreiben, ist mir dann doch ein bisschen zu heikel. Aber ich würde ja auch Caros Einschätzung eigentlich teilen. Also das, was wir im Bereich Rechtsextremismus beobachten, da braucht man jetzt auch nicht nur die Demos anzuschauen, das ist ja nur ein Teil der Geschichte. Es gibt ziemlich viele Autoren, die über die neue Rechte schreiben, kritisch schreiben. Oder vor allem Leute, die auch gar nicht so in der bundesweiten Presse aktiv sind, sondern eher Lokaljournalismus machen, die dann wirklich umziehen müssen, die vor Ort bedroht werden, vor deren Tür dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Schweineblut oder so etwas deponiert wird, die dann auch von lokalen Gruppen systematisch angegriffen, eingeschüchtert werden. Und ja, also das ist eigentlich seit Jahren eine Sache, die sich immer mehr verschlimmert hat. Und ich finde es auch mittlerweile auch ehrlich gesagt ziemlich hart, wie stark auch viele Journalistinnen, aber auch Autorinnen und Autoren verinnerlicht haben, dass das zum Job dazugehört. Und ich finde, das schwingt auch so ein bisschen mit in dieser Debatte, die wir jetzt hatten, um diese Drohbriefe, die zugesendet wurden an Christian Drosten und auch an andere, wo dann Herr Till Schweiger gesagt hat, naja, also nach dem Motto hier ist es doch nicht so dramatisch oder so, er hat sich hinterher dafür entschuldigt. Aber das zeigt eben auch so einen gewissen Zeitgeist, würde ich sagen, dass wir einfach dazu übergegangen sind, das für normal zu halten, also für unglaublich normal. Wenn ich mindestens zehn Morddrohungen in dem Bereich vorzuweisen und über Rechtsextremismus schreib, da denkt man auch so, ja, was hast du eigentlich falsch gemacht mittlerweile? Weil eigentlich ist das für normal. Es ist wirklich traurig, aber halt auch so Themen wie, was mache ich eigentlich mit dem Impressum in meinem Blog und so weiter, das ist ein Standardthema bei allen Leuten, die sich damit auseinandersetzen, weil du weißt, gerade wenn du in bestimmten Gegenden wohnst, sonst stehen die nächste Woche vor deiner Tür. Und wenn du Familie hast, hast du ein Problem.
Aber noch mal ab vom Rechtsextremismus, ist das auch etwas? Also Erzeugen, Verschwörungsmythen, Gewalt?
Also es gibt einen Zusammenhang, der da messbar war in Studien, dass man eben geschaut hat, wie ist die Gewaltbereitschaft. Und zumindest gerade im rechtsextremen Milieu wissen wir, dass ziemlich viele der Attentäter der letzten Jahre an Verschwörungserzählungen geglaubt haben. Beispielsweise an eine angebliche jüdische Weltverschwörung. Oder, also der Topseller der Rechtsextremisten ist ja so das Thema Umvolkung, Bevölkerungsaustausch. Und die haben damit ihre Taten legitimiert. Und ich meine klar, wenn ich meine Mitglieder, meine Anhänger so in dieses apokalyptische Weltbild ziehe, dass ich ihnen erkläre, wir stehen quasi an einem geschichtlichen Scheideweg. Ja, gibt es eine Elite? Politisch können wir halt eh nichts ändern, weil die Wahlen werden ja natürlich getürkt. Also sie werden gefälscht. Und alle Parteien stecken unter einer Decke. Die Medien auch. Die Medien sind Teil der Verschwörung. Die sind Feinde. Deshalb auch legitime Angriffstiere natürlich. Dann kann ich viel einfacher Gewalt legitimieren, weil ich da natürlich auch kommuniziere, sondern es gibt keinen anderen Weg. Weil die Medien sind Teil der Verschwörung. Ich brauch nicht mit der Presse zu reden. Die Politik ist Teil der Verschwörung. Da brauch ich gar nicht an Wahlen teilzunehmen. Und die Wahlergebnisse spiegeln dann ja auch angeblich nicht den wahren Willen der Bevölkerung wahr. Und die Repräsentanten, die da gewählt wurden, die haben keine Legitimität. Und natürlich kann ich damit in extremistischen Gruppen super Gewalt legitimieren. Das ist auf jeden Fall so.
Also es ist kein Automatismus. Also nicht jede Verschwörungserzählung führt automatisch zu Gewalt, aber kann dabei eine Rolle spielen. Ich würde gleich noch mal ein bisschen reden, obwohl Katta gerade gesagt hatte, das Internet hat nicht so viel Unterschied gemacht, würde ich trotzdem noch mal über die Rolle von Plattformen sprechen. Also wie da diese Dinge verteilt werden, welche Rolle sie da spielen und vielleicht auch, was die Verantwortung der Plattform da selber sein kann. Vorher hören wir aber noch eine kleine Musik von unserem De-Sendunging-Album Since Working overtime und zwar Double Jump und sind dann gleich wieder da. Das ist ein Double Jump vom Album Since Working Overtime von Lee Rosseweir. Hier beim Chaosradio 260, wo wir über Verschwörungserzählungen oder Lügen, die die Gesellschaft radikalisieren, sprechen. Wir haben schon ganz viel darüber gesprochen, welche das sind, wo die herkommen. Nicht, das machen wir jetzt. Welche das sind und was für Auswirkungen sie haben können. Und wo sie herkommen, doch zumindest inhaltlich schon. Aber ich würde jetzt tatsächlich nochmal die Informationsinfrastruktur, die Verschwörungserzählungen nutzen, besprechen wollen. Und da ist natürlich Hygienedemos quasi das Ende der Verbreitung, könnte man sagen. Welche Rolle spielen digitale, interaktive, soziale Medien? Vor allen Dingen Telegram. Wenn man das nur aus einem Auge verfolgt, ist das immer mal wieder vorgekommen. Telegram, ein Messenger, der sich als sicher ausgibt, aber bestenfalls als fragwürdig bezeichnet werden kann, aber der irgendwie einen Hort anscheinend für VerschwörungserzählerInnen ist. Warum?
Telegram gehört zu diesen sogenannten All-Tag-Plattformen in gewisser Weise. Einfach aus dem Grund, weil es den Ruf hat, eher sicher zu sein, was eher die Lüge ist, ehrlich gesagt. Und andererseits aber auch, weil es den Ruf hat, wenig zu moderieren oder gar nicht zu moderieren. Aus dem Grund haben sich vor ein paar Jahren Islamisten zusammengefunden. Es gab jahrelange ES-Kanäle, auf denen auch Rekrutierung stattgefunden hat. 2016, 2017, 2018 sind so die Rechtsextremen nachgerückt. Diese Entwicklung gab es auch in Deutschland. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass das jetzt seit Anfang Februar erst passiert ist, dass man sich dort quasi niedergelassen hat und seinen alternativen Kanal angelegt hat, sondern Martin Sellner zum Beispiel hat schon 2017 seinen ersten Telegram-Kanal angelegt und reichlich beworben, also zum Beispiel auch auf YouTube. Aktuell ist es so, dass man sieht, dass ziemlich viel auf Telegram passiert, dass es dort auch teilweise massiven Zuwachs gibt in verschwörungsideologischen und oder rechtsradikalen Kreisen. Und ich hab mir das jetzt über Wochen genauer angeguckt und meine These hat sich so ein bisschen bestätigt. Also es ist zum Beispiel nicht so, dass alle Akteure aus der rechtsradikalen Szene Zuwachs bekommen haben und da massiv Leute für sich gewonnen haben, sondern es sind tatsächlich die, die auch Verschwörungsideologien verbreiten. Und wir haben dankenswerterweise heute die meiste Zeit auf diese Namen verzichtet. Und ich glaube, ich sag sie jetzt auch nur einmal, aber Leute wie Xavier Naidoo und auch Attila Hildman haben dort relativ massiv und sehr schnell Zuwachs gewonnen, aber sind auch teilweise durch eben Menschen stark gepusht worden, die da schon lange im Verschwörungsideologischen Spektrum aktiv waren. Und auch die haben da teilweise zehntausende Leute dazugewonnen, die ihre Kanäle auf Telegram abonniert haben. Also es ist schon beeindruckend, wenn man das in dem Kontext sagen kann.
So viel zu Telegram und was für oder spielen andere Plattformen auch eine Rolle? Du hast jetzt YouTube gerade erwähnt bei dem einen Protagonisten. Spielen die eine besondere Rolle bei der Verbreitung von Verschwörungserzählungen und Mythen? Oder werden die dafür benutzt wie für alles andere auch?
Also Verschwörungserzählungen und Mythen sind ähnlich wie Falschmeldungen, auch nur dann wirklich erfolgreich, wenn sie überall stattfinden. Und das ist tatsächlich so. Also es gibt eben auch reichlich Zeugs auf allen anderen Kanälen. Das heißt, es gibt Organisationen für die Demos auf Facebook, in Facebook Gruppen zum Beispiel. Es gibt reichlich Kram auf Twitter, gerade unter Medienartikeln. Es gibt unglaublich viel auf YouTube, muss man sagen. Also YouTube ist zentral für die Verschwörungserzählungen, die wir gerade sehen. Und da passiert auch teilweise relativ wenig. Dafür gibt es aber auch wiederum eine Strategie, die dann wieder auf Telegram zurückgreift. Das heißt, wenn größere Kanäle, wie zum Beispiel der von Oliver Janich, ein Video auf YouTube veröffentlicht haben und das wird dann gelöscht, dann gibt es eben die Strategie, dass man es nochmal auf Telegram hochlädt und die Gefolgschaft jeweils dazu aufruft, das auf ihren eigenen Kanälen auf YouTube hochzuladen. Also auch da gibt es auch eine Wechselwirkung zwischen den Kanälen. Das heißt, im Prinzip ist es überall. Wir sehen es auch auf TikTok inzwischen, dass da reichlich Verschwörungsmythen unterwegs sind. WhatsApp spielt eine Rolle. Da gab es ja ganz zu Anfang diese Sprachnachrichten, an die sich jetzt schon keiner mehr so richtig erinnern kann, weil es gefühlt drei Jahre her ist. Aber eigentlich war es erst im März, dass da die verschiedensten Dinge per Sprachnachricht auf WhatsApp zum Beispiel verbreitet wurden. Also im Prinzip gibt es keine Plattform, auf der alles irgendwie nett und verschwörungsfrei ist.
Seht ihr die Plattformen da in der Pflicht, was dagegen zu unternehmen? Und vielleicht wird die Frage sogar noch ein bisschen weiter. Verschwörungserzählungen sind ja schlecht greifbar, weil vom Inhalt her sind sie ja einfach Quatsch. Es sind ja die Auswirkungen, die so dramatisch sind. Glaubt ihr trotzdem an...
Ja, das ist immer, finde ich, ein sehr schwieriges Thema, weil gerade bei Interviews in den letzten Wochen habe ich dann auch immer so rausgehört quasi, na ja, soll man das jetzt alles löschen, soll man das jetzt alles zensieren, soll man da stärker durchgreifen? Und ich muss sagen, ich finde, das ist eine ganz, ganz schwierige Frage. Denn wenn wir mal global betrachten, also nicht nur Deutschland anschauen, sondern auch andere Länder, da muss man ja sagen, wenn wir jetzt sagen würden, alles, was eine Verschwörungserzählung ist, das soll automatisch gelöscht werden, dann wären natürlich diverse Regierungen dazu übergehen, sehr merkwürdige Dinge als Verschwörungserzählungen zu definieren. Ja, beispielsweise alles, was die Opposition verbreitet. Und dann haben wir eben eine sehr, sehr, sehr schwierige Debatte plötzlich. Gleichwohl muss man natürlich aber sagen, dass diese Plattformen ja nicht nur so funktionieren, dass Leute was reinstellen und dann, weiß ich nicht, suchen sie gezielt nach etwas und stoßen da drauf, sondern wir wissen eben auch aus Untersuchungen der letzten Jahre, dass diese Vorschlagsalgorithmen bei YouTube schon eine Radikalisierungstendenz hatten. Das ging so weit, dass YouTube selbst irgendwann eingeräumt hat, ja, es gibt ein Problem. Weil man hatte nämlich festgestellt, dass Menschen, die Verschwörungserzählungsvideos schauen, dass das sehr treue Kunden sind sozusagen. Also ein sehr treuer Zuschauer. Und wenn ich jetzt in einer KI sage, maximiere mal die insgesamt Zuschauerzahl. Weil man muss ja, also je länger Leute zuschauen, desto höher sind ja vielleicht auch die Werbeeinnahmen, die ich damit generieren kann. Dann schlage ich eher Videos vor, wo sie dranbleiben. Und wenn eben Verschwörungserzählungen da halt diesen Effekt ganz stark, ganz eindeutig bringen, dann wird das eben mehr vorgeschlagen. Und da hat YouTube auch selbst irgendwann festgestellt, okay, die KI ist da so ein bisschen amok gelaufen. Wir müssen das jetzt zurückfragen.
Aha, also doch, die KI.
Genau, die KI ist schuld. Aber so einfach ist es eben nicht. Weil man muss ja sagen, warum hat die KI das festgestellt? Der Grund liegt natürlich auch in unserer Psyche irgendwo. Dass wir natürlich für solche Dinge grundsätzlich schon vor dem Netz anfällig waren. Und natürlich auch, dass wir auch dazu tendieren, Sachen, die besonders reißerisch sind oder halt irgendwie so aufregend oder hier wird eine Wahrheit enthüllt. Das finden wir natürlich halt auch erstmal spannend. Und man hat ja auch diesen Effekt, dass wenn du Menschen glaubhaft machst, die Medien lügen alle, dann ist natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand mehr YouTube guckt, ja auch irgendwo größer. Und man muss halt einfach schon sagen, dass diese Vorschlagsalgorithmen da schon eine Rolle spielen. Also gerade auch bei Facebook haben wir so ein Experiment im Rahmen unserer Buchrecherche gemacht und dann war es schon sehr offensichtlich, wenn ich so ein paar UFO-Gruppen beitrete, irgendwie weiß ich nicht, Hitler lebt in der Arktis, Hohelerde, was es da so gibt, dann werden einem sehr schnell andere Gruppen vorgestarkend, die halt so in dieses selbe Milieu gehen. Und da ist eben die große Frage, was für eine Rolle spielt das ja und wie kann man das gut lösen, dass das nicht mehr so stark stattfindet, weil ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass die Plattformen das jetzt unbedingt beabsichtigt haben. Ganz im Gegenteil, es ist halt unglaublich schlechte Presse so in dem Zusammenhang auch. Das möchte man eigentlich nicht. Man wollte einfach nur die Interaktionszeit maximieren. Und das hat eben so gewisse Side-Effects gehabt, die ziemlich hässlich sind. Und diese Side-Effects gibt es eben auch in anderen Bereichen, wenn wir uns angucken, wie beispielsweise bestimmte Nachrichten, die sehr reißerisch sind, die sehr emotional sind, wie die halt automatisch gepusht werden, weil sie eben viele Klicks verursachen. Da muss man sich halt auch fragen, wie wirkt das auf unsere Gesellschaft? Und ich finde, an der Stelle müssen wir ganz eindeutig diskutieren. Ich meine, zum Faktencheck kann ja Caro sicher noch mehr erzählen. Da sehe ich eindeutig Verbesserungsbedarf. Also jetzt ist es bei YouTube unter Videos zum Thema Chemtrails. Dann ist da halt unten so ein Link. Also Chemtrails ist eine Verschwörungserzählung, wo es dann eben heißt, die Bevölkerung will, die Regierung will uns irgendwie kontrollieren, dadurch, dass sie Gift versprüht. Und zwar in jedem Flugzeug, das über uns fliegt. Und deshalb sehen wir da so Streifen. Das glauben tatsächlich Menschen. Und da ist dann so ein Wikipedia-Link, wo ich mir denke, so ein Wikipedia-Link konkurriert ja nicht so gleichwertig zu einem super gut aufgemotzten Video.
Ich muss kurz was einschieben, weil das immer wieder bei mir aufblinkt, wenn wir drüber sprechen. Und zwar, ich entschuldige mich, das ist ein bisschen albern, aber wenn also die Flugzeuge dazu dienen, uns zu vergiften, aber wegen der Corona-Krise, das es ja nicht gibt, die Flugzeuge nicht mehr fliegen, dann passt das ja alles nicht zusammen. Ach so, deswegen muss man nicht mehr fliegen. Das ist quasi der Effizient. Das sind die effizienteren Chemtrails. Aber dieser Widerspruch finde ich ganz interessant. Also gerade weil es ja auch so ist, es gab das Reichsbürgertum, also es gibt keine BRD, das ist eine GmbH, das ist alles Quatsch. Sind das aber dann auch dieselben Leute, die jetzt das Grundgesetz verteidigen, also meinen zu verteidigen, die Maskenpflicht und das Versammlungskontaktverbot? Das heißt, wenn man Verschwörungstheorien glaubt, glaubt man wirklich alles, weil man sie alles irgendwie zurechtbiegt? Oder sind das verschiedene? Also sind die Chemtrail-Gläubige immer ganz disjunkt von der Menge her miteinander?
Also interessanterweise gibt es eine Reihe von Studien, die geschaut hat, was ist denn ein Indikator dafür, dass jemand an Verschwörungserzählungen glaubt. Und die haben dann eben festgestellt, naja, so ein sehr starker Indikator ist eben, dass jemand an schon eine andere Verschwörungserzählung glaubt. Und da gab es eine britische Studie, die hat beispielsweise untersucht, Verschwörungserzählungen zum Thema Tod von Prinzessin Diana. Die ist ja bei einem Autounfall gestorben, verursacht dadurch, dass sie von Paparazzis verfolgt wurde. Und da gibt es eben so Verschwörungserzählungen, wo es heißt, naja, das war der Geheimdienst, wahlweise der britische oder der israelische oder aber da steckt die Königsfamilie dahinter und dann gibt es noch die Verschwörungserzählung, eigentlich lebt sie. Und in dieser Studie konnte festgestellt werden, dass Menschen, die glauben, so der Tod, das war halt auf jeden Fall ein Komplott, die glauben eher auch gleichzeitig, dass sie noch lebt. Also die glauben teilweise Dinge, die sich gegenseitig widersprechen. Und jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, wie kann das sein? Na ja, aber der gemeinsame Nenner ist eben von diesen beiden Versionen, sag ich mal, dass man eben glaubt, die offizielle Geschichte, die stimmt nicht. Und das ist, würde ich sagen, das Hauptnarrativ, was dann da drüber steht, was auch dafür sorgt, dass man auch unterschiedliche Dinge, die sich gegenseitig ausschließen, dann glaubt. Es gab ja auch zum Thema Antisemitismus in Deutschland zur Nazizeit gab es ja auch sehr interessante Phänomene, dass gleichzeitig behauptet wurde, ja, es gibt eine jüdische Weltverschwörung, das ist eine kapitalistische Weltverschwörung und das sind halt so, nach dem Motto, das sind die Banker, das sind die Reichen. Und dann gleichzeitig gab es aber diese Verschwörungserzählung von der bolschewistisch-jüdischen Weltverschwörung, was sich ja irgendwo widersprechen sollte. Aber es war irgendwie kein Problem, diesen Widerspruch auszuhalten, weil man eben dann so ein übergeordnetes Narrativ hatte und dem hat man das dann eben untergeordnet.
Wahnsinn.
Ich glaube aber auch diese kognitive Dissonanz, das muss auch gar nicht so sehr überraschen, ehrlich gesagt. Also es gibt zum Beispiel ja auch in unterrechtsradikalen gleichzeitig die Ansicht, dass Migranten kommen, um Arbeitsplätze wegzunehmen, aber auch kommen, um sich vom Staat aushalten zu lassen. Also beide existieren in der gleichen Szene gleichzeitig und werden auf die gleiche Gruppe angewendet. Das ist nicht ganz neu.
Manchmal frage ich mich doch, ob meine Welt nicht einfacher wäre, wenn ich das auch einfach alles glauben könnte.
Dann könntest du 5G nicht benutzen. Das wäre nicht gut.
Okay, das stimmt. Schnelles Internet ist wichtiger.
Kann ich noch kurz zu den Plattformen?
Ja, da wollte ich eh geradezu hin zurück.
Also ich glaube auch, wie Katha schon sagte, dass es nicht unbedingt in jedem Fall absicht war. Aber was man sagen kann, ist, dass es ausreichend Hinweise gibt inzwischen, dass es zumindest teilweise schon vor Jahren erkannt wurde und man sich entschieden hat, eher nichts dagegen zu machen. Und das ist halt ein Teil des Problems. Gleichzeitig muss man sagen, dass auch Verschwörungsmythen gesamtgesellschaftlich relativ lange belächelt wurden. Und dass es gerade eigentlich etwas ist, was nicht nur die Plattform aushandeln müssen, sondern wir auch gesamtgesellschaftlich und Politik und Medien und alle sind beteiligt. Und ich glaube, da kommen wir auch noch mal darauf zu. Aber tatsächlich sehe ich gerade viele Parallelen zu der Diskussion um terroristische Inhalte zum Beispiel. Weil es eben genau da auch das, was Katha schon gerade angesprochen hat, diese Diskussion schon darum gab, welcher Staat bezeichnet was als Terrorismus. Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei vergleichen. Und auch da sind wir eigentlich noch nicht weit genug in der Diskussion und fangen jetzt tatsächlich schon mit der Nächsten an und führen sie alle leider gleichzeitig.
Aber ich würde jetzt gerne noch zwei Sachen zu Plattformen fragen. Das eine ist, es gibt ja dieses Begriff oder dieses Konzept der Filterblase, die aber mittlerweile verschieden bewertet wird. Weil Filterblase, das eine war so ein bisschen, man rutscht da in sowas rein und dann nimmt man diese neue Meinung erst an, weil sie eben in der Filterblase präsentiert wird. Und die andere, die also für meine Wahrnehmung zumindest in der theoretischen Diskussion jetzt langsam immer mehr an Gewicht gewinnt ist, dass sie sagt, also eine Einstellungsänderung findet durch Filterblasen nicht statt. Sondern es ist einfach nur, du siehst halt mehr vom selben, aber das ist halt einfach so. Wie seht ihr das? Gibt es Filterblasen? Und wenn ja, schaffen sie Verschwörungserzählungsglauben? Oder sind sie einfach nur sozusagen das Gefäß, wo man reinrutscht, weil man sich eh dafür interessiert, sag ich mal?
Also es gibt ja inzwischen relativ reichlich Angebote aus der Welt der Studien zum Thema Filterblasen. Und der Großteil sagt ja eigentlich inzwischen, dass es gar nicht so den starken Effekt hat. Also dass man teilweise mehr Informationen zum gleichen Thema oder aus dem gleichen Spektrum erhält, aber gleichzeitig noch andere Dinge wahrnimmt. Und das ist ja bei der Mehrheit, der Facebook nutzt, tatsächlich zum Beispiel auch so, dass man eben nicht das total homogene Feld von Freunden hat. Und da auch noch reichlich andere Informationen reinkommen. Die Frage ist dann vielleicht eher, welche Informationen sind dominanter und welche verbleiben oder verfangen auch mehr. Und da kommen wir wieder auf die Emotionalisierung zurück, die da eine Rolle spielt. Und gleichzeitig würde ich aber sagen, Telegram zum Beispiel ist eigentlich relativ abgeschlossen. Wenn man da in einer politischen Ecke unterwegs ist, dann bleibt man da auch und gerät jetzt nicht durch Zufall noch in irgendwelche anderen Spektren rein. Also es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man auf andere Kanäle stößt, weil halt viele Kanäle und Gruppen untereinander sich teilen und dadurch auch Reichweite verschaffen gegenseitig. Aber das sind eben auch Leute, die wirklich alle zum gleichen Spektrum gehören. Und Gegenrede findet eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr statt.
Kata, hast du da auch noch einen Take oder?
Ja, also das mit den Filterblasen ist halt so eine Sache. Also wir hatten, also Karo hat es ja schon sehr treffend zusammengefasst. Also es ist ja auch nicht so, dass wir im analogen Leben jetzt total Bock hätten, jedes Wochenende mit, also ich jedenfalls nicht, mit AfD-Wählern Bier trinken zu gehen und danach gehen wir auf eine Techno-Party. Wir machen die Nacht durch, weil es so lustig ist mit Heinrich. Also so sind die Menschen halt nicht. Man sucht sich ja seine Freunde oder sein Bezugsumfeld ja eher so wie man auch ähnlich selbst tickt. Und das führt dann auch dazu, dass meistens die anstrengenden Diskussionen dann oft im Familienkreis, so im politischen Bereich stattfinden. Weil im Privaten kann man sich ja schon aussuchen, ein bisschen mit wem man seine Zeit verbringt und mit wem nicht. Und manchmal spart man dann auch vielleicht ganz bewusst das Thema Politik aus. Es ist schon so, dass man sich natürlich selber auch sucht, in welche Gruppen man da reinrutscht. Ich würde aber schon sagen, dass so dieses, ja dieser Vorschlagsalgorithmus oder was wird besonders stark in die Timeline gepusht, dass das einen Effekt hat. Wie stark dieser Effekt ist, ist natürlich sehr unterschiedlich. Davon, über welche Plattform wir sprechen, ist natürlich unterschiedlich. Davon auch, über was familiar ist. Wir sprechen aber gerade, wenn wir über YouTube sprechen, würde ich schon sagen, dass das einen Einfluss darauf hat, wie schnell Leute mit Dingen in Kontakt kommen und wie schnell man von einem auf das andere kommt. Also wir haben im Rahmen unserer Recherche uns dann halt auch so Videos angeguckt und dann halt einfach konsequent geguckt, naja, was wird uns denn danach vorgeschlagen? Und dann konnte man wirklich sehen, ausgehend von einem Verschwörungsvideo über 5G gab es dann verschiedene Entscheidungswege. Der eine führte zu so religiösen Gruppen, wo man dann am Ende bei so der großen satanistischen Verschwörung irgendwie gelandet ist, wo dann angeblich irgendwie Angela Merkel mit irgendwelchen anderen Politikern irgendwie Satan anbetet. Vereinfacht gesagt, ein anderer Pfad führte dann zu dieser Erzählung von Exenmenschen, außerirdischen Exenmenschen, die die Welt regieren. Und da konnte man dann eben hinkommen, indem man halt einfach so guckt, was wird einem empfohlen. Wenn man dann zwei, drei Videos aus diesem Spektrum dann angeschaut hat, dann haben sich die Empfehlungen schon angepasst und das war früher eben deutlich stärker als heute. Ich würde aber schon sagen, dass das eine Rolle spielt.
In der Rolle wobei? In der Rolle dabei, Leute da reinzuziehen oder da drin zu halten?
Es ist ja schon eine bewusste Entscheidung, ob ich sage, ich gucke mir das an oder nicht. Ich finde, manchmal die Gefahr an diesen Filterblasen-Diskussionen ist, dass die ja auch ein bisschen die Verantwortung von Menschen rausnimmt und sagt, die sind jetzt alle rechtsextrem geworden, weil der YouTube-Algorithmus halt irgendwie doof ist. So ist es natürlich nicht. Da spielen natürlich auch menschliche Faktoren eine Rolle. Es kann aber ein Verstärker sein in bestimmten Situationen. So würde ich es halt eher sehen. Es ist halt ein Faktor von vielen. Also ein Beispiel, die Vorträgung spielt ja auch eine ganz bestimmte Rolle. Also ich gehe ja nicht, ich werde ja nicht neu geboren quasi. Als Kleinkind gehe ich auf YouTube und dann spielt sich mein politisches Leben auf YouTube ab, sondern ich bin ja vorgeprägt durch Schule, durch Medien, durch Freunde, durch Familie. Und die prägen auch mein Bild darüber, wie ich beispielsweise Medien wahrnehme, wie ich Wissenschaft wahrnehme. Und das spielt eine Rolle dafür, wie ich eben auch auf solche Verschwörungs-Sachen reagiere. Da würde ich sagen, ein Faktor von vielen, aber nicht überbedet.
Genau, ich würde gleich sozusagen dazu kommen, wie wir als Gesellschaft, aber auch privat damit umgehen. Ich habe noch zu den Plattformen oder den sozialen Medien noch eine Frage und zwar ist die, was ja immer wieder als Argument kommt für die Verbreitung von Verschwörungserzählungen ist, guck mal dieses Video, das hat ja eine Million Leute gesehen. Und ich frage mich, ob nicht das vielleicht ein größeres Gewicht hat, als es eigentlich sinnvoll wäre. Weil, dass da eine Million steht, das heißt ja erstmal überhaupt nichts, außer dass diese URL eine Million mal aufgerufen wurde. Ist das vielleicht gar nicht so klug, nur weil Dinge eine hohe Zahl haben in einer sozialen Plattform, die anzunehmen, als die es weit verbreitet? Also gibt man ihnen da vielleicht mehr Relevanz, als es sein müsste?
Na ja, es gibt schon Untersuchungen und Umfragen, die beispielsweise ermittelt haben, wie viele Menschen glauben, dass die US-Regierung heimlich Kontakt mit Aliens hatte und das der Bevölkerung verschweigt? Oder wie viele Menschen glauben an Chemtrails? Oder wie viele Menschen glauben daran, dass AIDS eigentlich in einem Labor entwickelt wurde und quasi ein Biokampfstoff ist? Und je nach Verschwörungserzählung kommt man dann schon auf Werte von um die 10%. Also Beispiel AIDS oder Ebola, diese These, dass es von irgendwelchen Regierungen entwickelt worden sei, das ist in unterschiedlichen Ländern schon relativ stark verbreitet, 10-20%. Da kommt man schon je nach Land drauf. Und von daher halte ich das schon für realistisch, dass zumindest ein Anteil der Menschen, die das schauen, das auch ernst meint. Also klar gibt es die Leute, die dann halt irgendwie beim Mittagessen sich langweilen und sich dann denken, ja geil wieder eine Verschwörungsdoku so zur Abendunterhaltung. Klar gibt es auch. Aber es gibt eben diese Umfragen, die zeigen, es gibt mehr Leute als man denkt, die daran glauben.
Meintest du nicht eben eher, dass sich Glaubwürdigkeit aus den Klickzahlen ergibt?
Also ich wollte erstmal nicht in Abrede stellen, dass es nicht Menschen gibt, die daran glauben. Ich frage mich aber sozusagen in der Berichterstattung über Verschwörungserzählungen, wird sowas, wir kommen jetzt zu diesem Teil, wie gehen wir als Gesellschaft und als Medien vielleicht damit um, wird sowas, wie soll man das sagen, da wird darüber berichtet, weil halt eine große Zahl unter diesem Video steht. Ich glaube tatsächlich, Karolin, was du gerade angesprochen hast, das glaube ich schon, dass man guckt das und dann sieht man, also man ist eh anfällig, man guckt das, sieht das, hat eine Million andere Leute irgendwie auch geil gefunden. Dass man das eher als Verstärker war, das kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Ich meinte eher sozusagen dieses...
Journalistische Aufwertung.
Ja, also im Sinne von irgendwo gehen drei Leute auf die Straße und schreien drei Wochen lang hintereinander Ausländer raus. Und auf einmal werden die in Talkshows eingeladen. Und Tom Burrow ruft an. Und sozusagen so ein bisschen ähnlich sozusagen, ah, guck mal, das Echsenmenschen-Video, das hat eine Million Views. Lass uns doch gleich mal einen kleinen Artikel drüber machen. Und die Frage, ob die Verbreitung von Verschwörungserzählungen dadurch protegiert wird, dass sie überhaupt erst wahrgenommen werden, nur aufgrund von dem, dass da eine Zahl steht.
Ja, man muss vor allem, also einerseits glaube ich, das ist ein valider Punkt, dass man schauen muss, was wertet man überhaupt durch Berichterstattung auf? Und dann ist der nächste Punkt ja noch, wie berichtet man darüber? Das ist ja auch ein wichtiger Punkt, ne? Also man kann jetzt zum Beispiel ja sagen, QAnon hat vielleicht irgendwie am Ende 1000 Anhänger in Deutschland. Das ist jetzt noch nicht per se, und das ist eine komplett aus der Luft gegriffene Zahl, aber das ist per se jetzt noch nicht berichtenswert vielleicht. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel in den USA ja durchaus Fälle von Gewaltanwendung aus diesem Spektrum, und in dem Fall wäre das ja wieder eine Relevanz. Ich glaube aber, es ist unglaublich wichtig, sich von diesen Metriken zu verabschieden, aber das ist leider auch so ein oft gesagter Satz, den wir glaube ich seit Jahren immer wieder sagen. Und ich habe das zuletzt zum Beispiel gehabt bei diesem Thema Widerstand 2020, wo ich tatsächlich... Genau. Also es gab jetzt ganz kurz im Rahmen auch dieser Hygienedemos, sogenannten Hygienedemos, eine angeblich neue Partei, die jetzt irgendwie alle unter einem Hut versammelt. Und wir hatten vorhin schon das Thema, dass es relativ schwierig ist, Menschen mit sehr gegensätzlichen Theorien wirklich zusammen zu organisieren. Und diese angebliche neue Partei hat relativ große Zahlen in die Welt getragen und hat eben gesagt, sie haben irgendwie zehntausende Mitglieder schon nach kurzer Zeit. Und ich habe tatsächlich alle Interviewanfragen als Expertin dazu abgelehnt. Und glaube auch, dass es richtig war und dass wir das vielleicht auch aus der Sicht sowohl als Expertin zum Thema als auch als Journalistin, würde ich sagen, man kann da auch einfach teilweise deutlich länger abwarten. Weil am Ende stellt sich heraus, laut eines Videos, das jetzt gerade ein paar Tage alt ist, sie haben tatsächlich irgendwie unter 100 verifizierte Mitglieder. Und ein Organisationsgrad, der irgendwie berichtenswert wäre, hat sich bei mir da schon nicht zu der Zeit irgendwie dargestellt. Das ist jetzt kein Verschwörungsideologisches Thema, aber es ist damit verbunden und es zeigt so ein bisschen, dass man schnell dabei ist, tatsächlich Zahlen für sich anzunehmen und dann zu sagen, dadurch ergibt sich Relevanz. Das sehen wir auch bei allem, was irgendwie Stimmungsmache, teilweise auch organisierte Stimmungsmache gegen einzelne Journalisten, gegen einzelne Satirevideos oder sonstiges betrifft. Also da lässt man sich relativ schnell in vielen Redaktionen noch in die Irre führen, würde ich sagen.
Also eine Standardfrage bei mir in den letzten Wochen bei Interviews war eben auch so, ja sehen Sie eine Spaltung der Gesellschaft? Und dann wusste ich halt auch nicht irgendwie, okay, leben wir eigentlich in derselben Realität, habe ich mich dann schon manchmal gefragt, weil, naja, also ganz ehrlich bei anderen Themen wie beispielsweise zum Thema Seenotrettung, sind Zehntausende in ganz Deutschland, über 100.000 Menschen auf die Straße gegangen. Die Berichterstattung war im Vergleich zu jetzt eher so meh. Umfragen zeigen, dass es eben auch für viele Menschen ein Thema ist. Und trotzdem wurde da jetzt nicht gesagt, ok, darüber müssen wir jetzt drei Wochen berichten, was ich im Umbringen sehr schade fand. Und wenn man sich jetzt diese Demonstration anguckt, sind es halt in manchen Städten halt ein paar Dutzend Leute, aber hat einen hohen Skurrilitätsfaktor. Und natürlich ist es auch so, dass die Zahlen aus Umfragen, aus Studien hergeben, also es gibt einen Anteil in der Bevölkerung, der das glaubt. Aber das ist jetzt nicht etwas, das neu ist. Also das gab es schon immer und es gab es auch schon immer, dass politische Bewegungen das für sich versuchen zu nutzen, als Mittel der Radikalisierung oder der Mobilisierung. Und das jetzt zu einer Spaltung hochzuschreiben würde, auch diesen Gruppen viel mehr Macht zu schreiben, als sie eigentlich haben. Ja, also ich meine, das Mobilisierungspotenzial für ein Wochenende oder zwei Wochenende ist nur eine Sache. Die Frage ist halt eben, hat das Dauer? Da würde ich halt eher sagen, bin ich erst mal skeptisch aus den genannten Gründen der fehlenden Gemeinsamkeiten? Und Spaltung der Gesellschaft, das fand ich halt ehrlich gesagt unmöglich, dass es dann auch so in einigen Berichten dann als das dargestellt war. Das ist es aus meiner Sicht überhaupt.
Vielleicht können wir gleich zu der Frage kommen, was ist denn eure Erwartung an Journalismus? Wie jetzt mit Verschwörungserzählungen und rechtsextremer Desinformationen, das würde ich wirklich einfach jetzt in einen Topf werfen, umgegangen werden soll in Zukunft? Ich muss normalerweise aber von diesem Interview mit Simone Raphael erzählen, die hat bei Belltower News auch einen Kommentar geschrieben zu dem Thema und meint, sie fühlt sich eigentlich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen an die Anfänge von Pegida, im Sinne von, wenige Leute machen viel Krach und finden überall statt. Und ihr habt jetzt gerade auch schon erzählt, dass man da schon vorsichtig sein muss, also macht man es überhaupt. Und dann ist es aber auch so, es gar nicht machen ist wahrscheinlich keine Option, deswegen von euch als Expertinnen, wie macht man es am besten? Erst mal nur Journalismus.
Also ich glaube, es ist wichtig darüber zu berichten, aber man muss das auch nicht alles live tickern, sondern eigentlich ist vielmehr die Frage, was passiert da? Gibt es da Übergriffe? Was für Menschen gibt es da? Und das reicht auch, wenn man das jetzt nicht jede Woche macht, tatsächlich, sondern sich vielleicht auch mal langfristig anguckt. Ich glaube, diese Ausgeruhtheit fehlt da und die fehlt an vielen Ecken im Journalismus ja immer wieder. Das ist ja nichts Neues. Also es ist wichtig zu sagen, wer organisiert sich da und wer mischt sich darunter, finde ich. Es ist wichtig zu sagen, dass da zum Beispiel auch nicht nur Rechtsextreme unterwegs ist. Das kann man sagen. Man kann aber auch gleichzeitig sagen, dass sie keine Anstalten unternehmen, größtenteils sich von Rechtsextremen, von NS-Fahrharmlosern zu distanzieren. Das sind alles wichtige Punkte. Aber ich hab jetzt auch ganz oft gesehen, dass irgendwie Promis, die vor Ort waren, irgendeine Rolle gespielt haben. Und dass das so ein bisschen Boulevardesque wurde. Also das halte ich für den absolut falschen Weg. Und ich glaube, es ist auch falsch, sich als Ministerpräsident eines gewissen Bundeslandes mit einem Aluhut-Träger, also einem sprichwörtlichen Aluhut-Träger in der Diskussion zu zeigen. Weil das eben auch eine gleichzeitig Aufwertung von teilweise wirklich abstrusen Erzählungen ist.
Kattascha?
Die Gleichsetzung, die wir auch im Bereich Klima ja schon seit Ewigkeiten haben. Dass man irgendwie gleichwertig false equivalence hat und irgendwie sagt, naja wir diskutieren jetzt mal so, als wären das alles gleichwertige, wissenschaftsbasierte Annahmen, die da diskutiert werden.
Hast du da im Subtext quasi gerade schon auch gesagt, man soll so eine Leute auch nicht in Talkshows einladen?
Also ja, Talkshows ist immer glaube ich noch mal ein ganz anderes Thema, über das man vielleicht noch mal reden sollte. Also da gibt es ja noch ein paar andere Missstände. Furchtbarerweise.
Ja, also das Stichwort nicht einladen. Das finde ich ist tatsächlich ein wichtiges, weil ich meine, gut, jetzt haben wir die Debatte über die Demonstration, ist halt die Frage, wie lange das halt noch ein relevantes Phänomen ist, beziehungsweise wie lange das als relevantes Phänomen wahrgenommen wird, wie lange darüber berichtet wird. Aber wir hatten ja auch in den letzten Jahren immer wieder Situationen, dass auch Politiker, gerade von der AfD, regelmäßig in Talkshows eingeladen wurden, die an anderer Stelle richtig krasse Verschwörungserzählungen verbreitet haben. Stichwort Umvolkung, großer Austausch. Und da ist meine Position einfach, wer so etwas verbreitet, der hat sich von einer rationalen Debatte über Migration einfach schon längst verabschiedet. Also würde ich persönlich, wenn ich die Einladungsliste zusammenstellen würde, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, das ist ein Gast. Also ich sag auch manchmal bei Talksendungen zu entsprechenden Themen, sag ich halt auch vorher so ja, frage ich immer, wer der Gast ist, weil je nachdem, wer da sitzt, dann würde ich halt auch sagen, so wichtig ist mir das nicht. Also ich musste halt mit niemanden von der AfD sitzen. Echt nicht. Und also ich finde momentan so die Situation zwiespältig, weil also natürlich diese Proteste werden aus meiner Sicht auch so ein bisschen überzeichnet, auch weil sie einen hohen Skurrilitätsgrad haben. Gleichzeitig bilden sie aber etwas ab, was viele Menschen in ihrem Umfeld auch beobachten. Dass halt Menschen plötzlich Verschwörungserzählungen verbreiten, denen man das vorher nicht zugetraut hätte. Und da finde ich das auch gut, wenn man auch gesellschaftlich vielleicht auch drüber diskutiert, wie geht man damit um, auch im privaten Umfeld, wenn man da beispielsweise stärker auch mal Beratungsstellen fragt, statt dem zehnten Bericht über die kleine Demo mit dem großen Skurrilitätsfaktor, vielleicht mal mit der Sektenberatungsstelle sprechen, was die eigentlich Angehörigen raten würden. Weil ich glaube, das würde ziemlich viele Leser interessieren. Ich würde gar nicht davon ausgehen, dass es jetzt irgendwie weniger Klicks produzieren würde. Und auch Wissenschaftler öfter mal zu Wort kommen lassen. Ich finde gerade in der Corona-Debatte fand ich das ganz angenehm, dass man da halt auch sehr stark Wissenschaftler im voller Grund hatte und da auch in weiten Teilen auch sachliche Debatte hat. Was bringt was, was bringt was nicht? Es ist eine neue Studie, die zeigt wieder was anderes. Gut, muss die alte revidiert werden. So ist Wissenschaft halt. Und da eben auch, sage ich mal, das als wissenschaftliches Phänomen irgendwo betrachten, wo es ja auch eine jahrzehntelange Vorarbeit gab. Da freue ich mich auch wirklich, dass meine Co-Autorin Pia Lamberte, die ja auch zu dem Thema forscht, zahlreiche Fachartikel in Pia Reviewed Zeitschriften veröffentlicht hat zum Thema mit Studien und so weiter, dass sie halt auch momentan sehr stark angefragt wird. Weil das, finde ich, auch der Problematik gerecht wird, dass man eben nicht sagt, so hoch, wo kommen die denn jetzt seit zwei Wochen her, sondern wirklich, wie ist die Genese dieses Milieus in den letzten Jahrzehnten?
Glaubt ihr, ich hänge jetzt gerade so ein bisschen dran, also Journalismus soll berichten und aber auch aufklären und sozusagen zur Seite stehen und begleiten. Und ich bin jetzt gerade irgendwie im Hängen geblieben am Anfang, dass du gesagt hast, dass man, oder es einen Zusammenhang gibt zwischen gesellschaftlich sicherer Stelle oder unsicherer. Je unsicherer sozusagen, desto mehr Übereinstimmung gibt es auch mit Verschwörungserzählungen. Glaubst du, dass Bildung trotzdem helfen kann, vor Verschwörungserzählungen zu schützen? Oder ist es, braucht es eher eine sicherere Gesellschaft? Und die Bildung spielt eigentlich gar nicht so eine Rolle. Weil Bildung, sozusagen Bildung hilft nicht vorm Kontrollverlust.
Ja, sagen wir mal so, ich hätte mich sehr gefreut, wenn ich in der Schule mehr zu Thema Psychologie als Unterrichtsfach gehabt hätte. Also später im Studium hatte ich halt viel zum Thema, ja weiß ich nicht, sogenannte Anomalies. Also sag ich mal, wo gibt es psychologische Effekte, die dafür sorgen, dass wir uns in einer bestimmten Art und Weise verhalten oder nicht verhalten. Was ja auch ganz oft in marktrelevanten Situationen so eine Sache ist. Beispielsweise, dass man eher so eine Loss-Aversion, also Verlustangst hat. Oder dass es halt bestimmte Urteils-Heuristiken gibt, die dazu führen, dass wir verzerrte Wahrnehmungen in einigen Bereichen haben. Also nicht objektiv-rationale, vor allem eigentlich fast in allen Bereichen genauer gesagt. Und so eine Grundbildung, würde ich sagen, persönlich, fände ich total geil, wenn man das in der Schule hätte. Und wenn ich beispielsweise weiß, dass ich in bestimmten Situationen einfach anfälliger für bestimmte Dinge bin, dann kann ich vielleicht auch mich selber reflektieren in solchen Situationen. Und hab vielleicht noch so einen letzten Moment, der mir einen halt gebietet, bevor ich da halt total auf diesen Zug aufspringe. Und natürlich gibt es so in allen Bereichen diese Tendenz, alles auf den Lehrplan zu packen, so nach dem Motto, das können wir lösen, indem wir den Lehrplan einfach noch mehr aufwerten. Aber ich würde tatsächlich sagen, so eine psychologische Grundbildung, die fände ich wirklich in ziemlich vielen Bereichen ziemlich geil. Und dafür würde ich auch auf die ein oder andere, weiß ich nicht, Gedichtinterpretation auch durchaus verzichten wollen.
Die Deutschlehrerinnen der Welt schreien auch.
Wenn ich Gourmails von Germanisten bekomme, ja oder meinetwegen halt auch im Bereich Mathematik oder Physik. Also ist halt auch alles wichtig, aber Psychologie hat man halt in ziemlich wenigen Bereichen. Und das finde ich schade, weil eigentlich, wenn man sich anguckt, welche Rolle das bei unseren Entscheidungen spielt, immens. Und es gibt auch Unterrichtsmaterial, beispielsweise von der Amadeo-Antonio-Stiftung, wo sie eben hingegangen sind und gesagt haben, naja, wie sprechen wir mit Schulklassen über Verschwörungserzählungen? Da war halt eben so ein Konzept, dass man sagt, naja, dann denkt euch beispielsweise welche aus und guckt euch gemeinsam an, was sind so Mechanismen? Und wenn ich das mal selber durchgespielt habe, dann erkenne ich das auch eher, wenn mir das über den Weg läuft. Es gibt spielerische Ansätze, es gibt Computerspiele, wo man quasi selber so ein Informationsvirus bauen muss, der sich dann verbreitet. Also Studien zeigen, dass es halt ultra effektiv ist, um bei Kindern und Jugendlichen dazu anzuregen, dass sie so etwas eher erkennen und dann auch eher so eine Art Frühwarnung.
Tatsächlich aber auch bei Älteren. Also es gibt von der Uni Cambridge ein Spiel, das auch gerade eher ältere Menschen, die durchaus Falschmeldungen und auch Verschwörungsideologien verbreiten, auch gespielt haben. Und bei denen war das auch teilweise besonders wirksam. Und was mir in dem Bereich bildet und immer noch wichtig ist, ist, dass wir auch endlich noch mal viel mehr über Menschen reden, die nicht über das Schulsystem erreichbar sind, weil wir da einfach überhaupt keine vernünftigen Lösungen haben. Also das reicht eben nicht, da nur über die VHS zu gehen, wo eh nur Leute hingehen, die eh schon sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen wollen. Und mir fehlt das total im journalistischen, im politischen, im alltäglichen Diskurs, dass wir das mal wirklich anpacken und darüber reden. Weil ich so das Gefühl hab, wir lassen jetzt einfach alle Generationen, die nicht mehr zur Schule gehen, einfach mal machen und hoffen, dass es dann mit der nächsten, sobald der Bildungsplan oder Lehrplan dann irgendwie entsprechend eingepasst ist, was dann sowieso erst in den nächsten who knows wann Jahren passiert. Also das finde ich unglaublich wichtig, das auch immer noch zu betonen, weil es gibt eigentlich kaum bis keine vernünftigen Angebote, die ich auch einfach mal zur Hand an die Hand geben würde. Weil es fängt ja auch schon bei Lehrern an, die eigentlich gar nicht wissen, wie sie mit dem Internet umzugehen haben, die teilweise auch Selbstverschwörungsideologien verbreiten. Also da ist reichlich zu tun an ganz vielen Stellen.
Also Bildung gar nicht so sehr als Aufklärung gegen die Verschwörungserzählung, also faktische, sondern eher für die Mechanismen breitmachen und aufklären und Impulskontrolle im Selbst ermöglichen, sage ich mal. Das ist ja, also sowohl dieses Bildungs- als auch Deutons-Thema, das ist ja gesellschaftlicher Kontext. Also da reden wir über das große Ganze. Was mich berührt hat, war Kattascha, ein Thread von dir, wo du gesagt hast, ich weiß, der ist jetzt schon ein paar Wochen alt, wo du gesagt hast, der für mich so hängen geblieben ist, als die Menschen, die in der Nähe von Menschen sind, die in Verschwörungserzählungen abgeleiten. Das sind ganz wichtige Bausteine in dem Schutz, oder in dem möglicherweise das zu verhindern, dass es endgültig passiert. Wie macht man das, wenn man das bei sich beobachtet?
Ja, zunächst einmal ist es immer schwierig, sag ich mal. Wir haben im Bezug darauf mit Beratungsstellen gesprochen, die eben auch mit Angehörigen zu tun haben, die sich dann recht verzweifelt an sie wenden und sagen, naja, irgendwie mein Partner hat sich verändert, meine Schwester hat sich verändert. Und wir haben auch mit Angehörigen gesprochen von Menschen, die an Verschwörungen glauben, die halt wirklich auch verzweifelt waren. Die uns berichtet haben, dass beispielsweise Angehörige dann sich bei einer schweren Erkrankung nicht mehr behandeln lassen wollen. Also wo man wirklich Angst hat, dass derjenige stirbt, weil er eben an eine Verschwörung der Schulmedizin war, angeblich eine Schulmedizin glaubt. Also Schulmedizin ist ja auch ein schwieriger Begriff aus diesem Umfeld, hat auch so eine recht braune Vergangenheit, muss man dazu wissen. Und also grundsätzlich muss man sich darauf einstellen, dass es eher ein Marathon als ein Sprint ist. Weil oft muss man, also oft wird man erst darauf aufmerksam, dass jemand da in so ein Milieu abgerutscht ist oder in so eine apokalyptische Gedankenwelt, wenn das recht weit fortgeschritten schon ist. Also dann wird es halt plötzlich dann am Essentisch ausgesprochen und oft hat man so den Impuls, boah, ich will jetzt echt keinen Stress am Familientisch, ist jetzt gerade so beschaulich, heute streiten wir uns mal nicht, lassen wir das mal so. Und das Problem ist, dass Beratungsstellen ja wirklich sagen, das ist der falsche Weg. Je früher man eingreift, desto besser. Weil meistens ist es so, dass man in so ein Sog gerät. Also gerade wenn man sich über bestimmte Quellen, bestimmte Influencer informiert, dann ist es manchmal so, dass diese Akteure sich teilweise auch in dieser Zeit radikalisieren. Das beobachtet man ja auch bei einigen, die jetzt so zum Thema Corona so jetzt sehr hervorgehoben sind, wo man das Gefühl hat, so okay, jeden Monat sind die noch mal im Level weiter. Andererseits wird man ja auch auf andere Akteure aufmerksam, die halt immer noch mal einen Schritt weitergehen. Das heißt, von der, sag ich mal, irgendwie, dass man sagt, so ja, an dem Thema Impfen, da ist halt so ein bisschen was dran. Kann es halt sein, dass man über Akteure, die dann dazu schreiben, halt irgendwann wirklich zu Gruppen kommt, die behaupten, so es gibt halt eine geheime Weltregierung und die unterdrückt jetzt hier Wissen. Und an der Stelle ist es dann wirklich fast zu spät mit einem, oder eigentlich zu spät mit einem Faktencheck zu kommen, weil dann halt so dieses Argument ist so ja, das Faktencheck von der, das ist doch von der Presse, die ist doch Teil der Verschwörung, glaube ich nicht. Wissenschaft auch, dasselbe. Das heißt, je früher eingreift, desto besser, weil am Anfang, wenn die Leute noch so in diesen unterschiedlichen Informationswelten sind, kann man noch am ehesten zu ihnen durchdringen. Und wenn es halt wirklich so ist, dass der Glaube halt wirklich sehr weit fortgeschritten ist und man auch so das Gefühl hat, dass es so eine allumfassende Welterklärung geworden ist, dann helfen meistens halt nur noch Fragen. Also wirklich vorsichtig vorantasten und wirklich immer wieder hinterfragen, warum glaubst du das, woher weißt du das, ist der Experte, warum ist der Experte, warum glaubst du, der ist mehr Experte als der andere Experte. Also einfach nur Fragen stellen, damit der andere das selbst reflektiert und auch nicht das Gefühl hat, dass man von oben herab mit ihm spricht. Also auch wenn es oft anstrengend ist, dann halt nicht laut werden, nicht ungeduldig werden, auf gar keinen Fall von oben herab belehrend. Und da halt wirklich immer am Ball bleiben. Und manchmal kann es halt auch einfach nur helfen zu fragen, so hör mal, wie geht es dir eigentlich? Also Stichwort Kontrollverlust. Also gerade wenn wir doch wissen aus wissenschaftlichen Studien, dass Krisen ein Katalysator dafür sein können, dass Menschen halt sich so verändern, dann kann es ja auch sein, dass wenn ich diese Krise versuche zu lindern oder wegzunehmen, dass dann dieser Drang zur Flucht in so eine Fantasiewelt gar nicht mehr so groß ist. Und zumindest in einigen Fällen kann das klappen. Und vor allem, wenn ich so eine emotionale Brücke zu jemandem aufbaue, dann kann ich darüber ja auch später viel eher argumentativ gehen. Wobei man gleichzeitig sagen muss, man muss halt an vielen Stellen da halt auch wirklich eine rote Linie ziehen. Beispielsweise Antisemitismus, Rassismus. Das muss man ganz klar als solches benennen. Da sollte man auf gar keinen Fall schweigen oder halt denken, ich darf das jetzt nicht eskalieren. An der Stelle muss man auch eskalieren, weil da geht es eben auch um andere. Und man muss an irgendeiner Stelle sich auch fragen, so schaffe ich das? Also einige Angehörige, die sagen dann halt auch, wir haben den Kontakt irgendwann abgebrochen, weil es nicht mehr ging. Weil wir beispielsweise unsere Kinder auch davor schützen wollten, dass sie Kontakt mit den Reichsbürgern haben. Weil diese Leute auch teilweise auch irgendwann aggressiv werden können, wenn sie glauben, dass man Teil der Verschwörung ist. Und im Zweifel sollte man sich da auch Hilfe suchen. Also Verbündete im Umfeld, Freunde, Familie oder eben auch Beratungsstellen. Und da würde ich wirklich dazu raten, Sektenberatungsstellen gibt es in unterschiedlichen Bundesländern, auch in der Schweiz, Österreich. Die haben viel Erfahrung damit, weil es eben diese Überschneidung gibt, zu vielen Sekten-Gurus, die dann Verschwörungserzählungen verbreiten. Oder eben mobile Beratungen gegen Rechtsextremismus beim Thema Reichsbürger.
Aber das heißt, es gibt schon einen Unterschied in der Art, wie wir als Gesellschaft, im Großen und Ganzen, und als Medien damit umgehen und im Privaten, nämlich dieses Verständnis zeigen. Als ich das zum ersten Mal gehört habe, hat sich mir der Widerspruch aufgemacht, was sich Pegida zu Nutze gemacht hat, ist, wir sind die besorgten Bürger. Das ist ja eben genau dieses Verständnis einfordern. Das kann im Privaten also funktionieren, aber man kann es nicht als gesellschaftliche Strategie annehmen.
Ich glaube, es gibt schon...
Man muss unterscheiden, ganz klar zwischen... Vielleicht noch diesen einen Punkt. Man muss an der Stelle ganz klar unterscheiden zwischen öffentlich und privat. Das, was ich eben geschildert habe, ist ein Feld in meinem Umfeld, an meinem Essenstisch, ein Verwandter oder ein enger Freund. Was anderes ist, wenn ich das online sehe, in der Öffentlichkeit sehe, da ist Gegenrede absolut wichtig. Da muss man auch ganz klar hier einen Fakten checken. Es ist egal, ob ich das gegenüber überzeuge. Das will ich gar nicht. Ich will den stillen Mitglädern zeigen, dass ich nicht der Meinung bin. Ich muss auch nicht als Ministerpräsident hingehen und mit den Leuten verständnisvoll sprechen. Ich bin nicht der Angehörige, ich bin der Ministerpräsident. Das sind eben diese unterschiedlichen Rollen. Wenn ich aber meinen Gegenüber wirklich überzeugen will und nicht in eine öffentliche Debatte gehe, dann sind Vier-Augen-Gespräche einfach wichtig. Da muss man aber auch klar trennen. Es schließt sich nicht aus, dass ich im Familienchat Onkel Heinrich ganz klar sage, das ist hier antisemitisches Zeug, hier Faktencheck. Sorry, geht gar nicht. Entweder du hörst damit auf oder du fliegst aus dem Familienchat und gleichzeitig den später anrufen und sagen, wie kommt es eigentlich dazu, dass du so was verbreitest? Es können gleichzeitig Strategien sein. Bei der einen geht es darum, Dritte zu schützen oder zu verhindern, dass derjenige das in einer großen Gruppe ausbreitet. Gerade bei Rassismus, Antisemitismus, das kann einfach zu Gewalt führen gegen Menschen.
Nein, das kam jetzt zum Ende tatsächlich noch mal. Was mir auch noch mal wichtig war, glaube ich, zu sagen, dass es bei beiden eben auch diese Grenzen gibt. Dass man eben Entmenschlichungen und Antisemitismus, Antisemitismus, antimuslimischen Rassismus und so weiter eben nicht zulässt. Dass es eben bei beiden gleich nur, dass man eben in Sachen Aufwertung und gleichwertiger Darbietung von Meinungen in dem Medium noch viel, viel mehr vorsichtig sein muss und auch aufpassen muss, inwiefern man anerkennt, dass das eben eine kleine, sehr laute Minderheit ist, der man da jetzt sehr, sehr viel Raum gibt.
Und damit sind wir am Ende dieser Erzählung angekommen. Würde ich sagen, wenn ihr beiden nicht noch sozusagen ein letztes Wort habt, dass ihr an die Werte Gemeinde richten wollt als Kultleiterin des Chaosradios für heute?
Ja, als Kultleiterin wünsche ich mir möglichst bald möglichst viel 5G in Berlin, damit dieser Horror mit abbrechenden Telefonverbindungen und Videostreams und was man nicht gesehen hat, endlich ein Ende hat.
Das Internet ist nicht die Lösung. Das Internet ist nicht die Lösung, zumindest aktuell nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank, dass ihr beide heute hier wart und so ausführlich mit mir darüber gesprochen habt. Karolin Schwarz, Hasskrieger, der neue globale Rechtsextremismus ist das Buch. Du hast eigentlich auch einen Podcast, also bist Teil eines Podcasts, Filterbabel. Wie läuft, lohnt es sich noch, den zu abonnieren? Kann man da bald wieder was hören?
Unklar aktuell.
Viel zu tun. Viel zu tun, na gut, aber du hast ihn noch nicht aufgegeben? Und Katharina Nocuni zusammen mit Pia Lamberti das Buch Fake Facts wie Verschwörungstheorien unser Denken bestimmen, gerade rausgebracht hat und auch einen Podcast hat, nämlich Denkangebot. Wie sieht es da aus?
Ja, das Problem ist, ich habe eigentlich das Material für die nächste Folge Zeit genommen. Und ich habe noch voll Stress gemacht, hier müssen wir das Interview machen und jetzt habe ich sechs total geile Interviewpartnerinnen gehabt und wurde dann wegen dem Buch etwas vom Medieninteresse überrascht und hoffentlich habe ich bald Zeit daraus eine ganz tolle Folge zum Thema Corona zu machen.
Alles klar, also bleibt dran, folgt den beiden, wo immer ihr kennt, in den Show Notes werden die passenden Links dazu stehen. Vielen Dank nochmal, dass ihr hier wart. Ich sage an dieser Stelle schon mal Tschüss.
Tschüss, hast's gut.
Und liebe Hörerinnen, für euch sage ich wie immer noch ganz zum Schluss, lasst ihr nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.